Travel Channel professional explorers
subject-matter expert on all things
mysterious Josh gates journeys across
continents to uncover evidence of aliens
expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials premieres tonight at
9:00 8:00 central on Travel Channel Josh
joins us here in our LA man cave good to
see a standard-issue clothing I see that
you're ready to go tackle yeah now is
that for aliens or is that for this for
all truth seeking you have to have a
kind of adventure shirt an adventure
coat it's you know you'd be ready at any
moment to investigate a mystery okay
now the most fascinating thing that I
read about you is that you have a tattoo
sort of so the very first show that I
did was a competition reality show for
ESPN called beg borrow and deal Rich
Eisen Rich Eisen hosted it yeah and it
was a million years ago
are you having like a moment where
you're remembering me from a decade ago
Dan I think we met him before I think we
met we met before he didn't you come to
Bristol for this I I don't know have I
don't we this is like I totally see it
amazing what Dad did or not maybe with
this this was legitimately like 15 years
ago right this was a long time ago so it
was a competition reality show you had
to beg your way across the country I was
on a team of four people and you had to
do sports related tasks along the way
this was sort of the great amazing
Amazing Race before that yeah this was
like ESPN's crack at doing a big Amazing
Race as I'll show and you had a list of
50 sports related tasks you had to
complete ten of them and make it from
Times Square to Alcatraz Island where
Eisen would be waiting and if you could
do that and complete ten tasks you would
win the show and we had completed nine
tasks on this list and and one of the
lay up things on this list that you
could do was each member of the team get
a tattoo at least the size of a quarter
of your favorite sports team logo now
I'm not a big sports guy which is
probably one of the reasons I ended up
on that show I'm like the big guy who
seems like he should know things about
sports and I and I don't like you could
be alignment yeah and in high school
they oh you know my dad was a big
football player they always wanted me to
go over I just not a sports guy and so
that was people
that was funny so that's how I think
that's the only reason I was on that
show and but I wanted to win you know so
the very last thing we did in California
to win the show was we each got a tattoo
so I think two people on the team I
think got a Yankees logo
I got a Boston guy I got a Red Sox B on
the bottom of my foot and the reason I
got it there and they and the other guy
got a Clemson Tiger South Carolina guy
and the reason I got it there is I was
told that if you get tattoos on the
bottoms of your feet they might come off
over time because this again would slice
off you know and I and I didn't want a
Red Sox tattoo for the rest of my life
so got out of the bottom of my foot it
was there it didn't fade it was there
for about three or four months woke up
one day looked at the bottom of my foot
totally gone
but that's a mystery that's a mystery
explain the show that what the new show
the new show yeah
expedition unknown we go around the
world and we investigate legends and
mysteries so everything from lost
treasures vanished explorers lost cities
you know all that cool stuff and we go
and we work with explorers and
archaeologists that are like out in the
world doing this stuff we link up with
them and we tell the story of the thing
that they're after and hopefully we're
there when they find some cool stuff
that's that's the basic idea of the of
the main show and we're doing a big
four-part special that kicks off tonight
on the subject of extraterrestrials okay
so we're going all over the world
hunting for ETS
give me a story that is gonna make me
think twice about the extraterrestrials
or aliens out there well there's kind of
two different angles to the
extra-terrestrial thing one is the
science angle which is is there life out
in the universe at large and the other
one is the experience or angle have they
been here you know these these people
who claim they've been ducted or they've
seen things so I left this special this
this this 4-part special I am now a 100%
believer that there is life in the
universe because we met with some of the
brightest minds on the planet in the
show tonight we go behind the scenes at
Mission Control at NASA and Houston we
spoke
with the astronauts in the space station
we talked to the best of the best and
there's now this this consensus really
among scientists that it would be crazy
at this point if there isn't life out
there you know I think 20 years ago
we thought oh there may be no planets
like Earth weird this really unique
thing now they're finding earth-like
planets like every month but what kind
of pushed you over the edge where you go
I'm a hundred percent in on this you
know going we went to South America and
hung out with these guys who operate one
of the largest telescopes in the world
and these guys are finding planets that
potentially have an atmosphere gravity
they're the right distance from their
star their earth-like and so you realize
now that there may be millions if not
billions of planets that fit the bill
and so at a certain point you have to
kind of say why wouldn't there be life
somewhere else now the second part of
the question have they been here yeah
that's that's that's a tougher nut to
crack and I'm Way more skeptical about
that and we met people who had these
incredible experiences and I will say
there were some cases where I walked
away from interviews and I said I cannot
explain what happened to this guy I
don't know if that means that well what
happened we went for instance and I
think the second or third show we went
to Zimbabwe in Africa which is home to
one of the largest mass UFO sightings in
history so at a school in Zimbabwe about
15 years ago the kids in this school
described this event where a craft
silently landed a huge you know like I
mean like 1950 style flying saucer right
like out of a movie
landed in this field at the edge of
their school this was seen by nearly a
hundred students raging ranging from
kind of you know young elementary school
to high school all describing the same
thing all seeing the same thing these
kids were we spoke to some of the
teachers the headmistress at the school
people were screaming crying I mean in
complete panic they separated all these
kids took him to their separate
classrooms they weren't even all in the
same classroom asked them to draw what
they'd seen and interviewed them all
they all saw the same thing and we got
about a dozen of them together fifteen
years later brought them back to the
school sat them down to hear their story
and I left
the interview feeling as though these
kids 100% believe that this happened you
know I mean they there's almost a trauma
to it and none of them were selling
t-shirts none of them had a best-selling
book nobody was trying to cash in on no
reality show no reality show
no Rich Eisen hosted no Christian Bob
way nothing and you know they'd been
through something so I left going I have
no idea what these kids saw I just I'm
stumped and that's what that's kind of
the fun of this too is that you meet
these people with these crazy
experiences and you have to try to
figure it out the show is Expedition
unknown hunt for extraterrestrials on
Travel Channel and he's Josh gates he
journeys across continents to uncover
evidence of aliens expedition unknown
hunt for extraterrestrials premieres
tonight at 9:00 Eastern on Travel
Channel is there one that you've yet
liked that would be the highest on your
list to try to crack the code with but
what is you're right I'm obsessed with
Amelia Earhart we did a show on her in
the first season I love her I have a
huge fascination with with with her and
I would love to be able to spend my
career just hunting down Earhart's plane
and I think it probably could be found
with enough resources but I think it's
an expensive endeavor so I that to me is
kind of the holy grail of mysteries well
what about the photo that they just
uncovered recently where it looks like
she might be in the background of a
photo in off an island off of Japan I
think that's right yeah this was like an
amazing story and I like a lot of people
got really excited about it for a second
and then fairly quickly a kind of you
know disintegrated that a researcher
discovered the photo in an archive that
it had been taken and published even a
number of years before she vanished so
it was this kind of moment of oh maybe
we've got this which is like so many
other things in the Earhart case there
are all these kind of great false leads
that that unfortunately kind of
evaporate over time you got a sports
miss mystery that you can solve or you'd
want to solve you tell me I'm trying to
do 20 of these shows a year talk to me
what do we got a missing trophy a
missing what what what can I go do in
the sports realm you tell me McLovin
bloody soccer chili
[Music]
well that's just from a Yankee
perspective they don't believe in the
bloody sock I I believe in the bloody
side about Babe Ruth pointing no ballin
is shelling a homerun shot at Wrigley
Field
yeah deflategate snarky I could I you
know as a New England guy is a Boston
guy that's dangerous territory for me
but your scientists disapprove that one
already do you want to tackle it just so
you can kind of exonerate Tom Brady sure
but who knows where this will lead
territory let's not kid ourselves how
about you don't think any of us are a
hundred percent convinced why don't you
do the Patriots and we could put a lot
on you know spy games I mean there's a
lot of things a lot you're just going to
investigate the Patriots yeah that feels
like a dangerous mission welcome back
I'm gonna end up in a parking garage
talking to somebody in the shadows you
know yeah Paulie I I grew C know if you
did the the Babe Ruth one there's been a
lot of like sports guys who done it but
to have a non sports person to look at
it objectively you know I would love to
do that I think one of the things as the
show goes on that we're exploring more
and more is you know it's not all vanish
temples and lost explorers I think that
we're trying to do things in lots of
different spaces so as much as we're
kind of gagging around about it it's
totally possible to do something like
that
I'd like I got one of the Immaculate
reception with Franco Harris did the
ball carom off a teammate Frenchy fuqua
where he caught it just off the grass
and are the astroturf ran in for a
touchdown then they went to the Super
Bowl that one is still they've got just
a couple of camera angles there they
didn't even know where the football was
after the touchdown right so there's
there's mystery with that was it a legal
catch that might be one as well young
people also how the Lakers get Kobe
Bryant how they char Lee to trade for
Kobe Bryant I'm actually sensing a full
spin-off series here this is maybe we
should be doing the sports version and
somebody called my agent off-camera
please lock up exact effects of edition
of sports mysteries all the title please
hit Legal Zoom on this right now
trademark this sucker right type of
treatment yes good luck with the show
he's Josh gates
expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials on Travel Channel
expedition unknown hunt for
extraterrestrials premiers tonight at
9:00 8:00 central on Travel Channel good
luck in your travels thank you so much
and great to have you in here and let us
know if you do do a sports one we'd be
very interested in talking about that or
helping you with it recently I actually
love that idea I'm into it maybe this
audience can help too if they could send
in things yeah you know you can email us
or tweet at us yelling maybe he can
investigate why some of us today
couldn't find an iron or a shower
because we look slobbing lee I don't
think he does that there's only so far
you'll go
that's the some mysteries that can't be
solved how long have you gone without a
shower ah that's a great question I
think we're definitely over a week
oh maybe nine ten days Wow fly you out
to Ecuador and you're in the middle of
this cave there's not like a five-star
that they just helicopter you know in
and out it's not Canada I just ran into
another Travel Channel host in an
airport something that I have waited
it's bound to happen yeah and we had
been filming in the same town in South
America and he said boy hasn't this been
amazing down here they've got me in this
beautiful five-star place up in the
mound you want to mention who this is
now he knows no well but we don't know
it's all right he knows now is there no
I'm sleeping on like dirty Airport
floors we just filmed this episode in
Ecuador where we slept in a cave under
bats just peeing on us all night and we
were down there for three or four days
no sunlight filming underground three of
us ended up in the hospital with severe
rotavirus which I now know who is
something you don't want to have could
you could you take this other Travel
Channel guy he's definitely handsomer
than me which is the problem but he's
also significantly older needless
needless this Anthony Bourdain no he's
he's he's gone on to other pastures he's
he's over at CNN now is his first name
Jack Maxwell no I got nothing bad to say
about Jack Maxwell I got nothing bad to
say about any of the Travel Channel guys
all great I'm just kidding all right we
got to figure this out Josh thank you
for coming in it's uh expedition unknown
and we have a shower in the back if you
need to take one here premieres tonight
at 9:00 8:00 central on Travel Channel
the Dan Patrick show weekday mornings on
audience